portraits that seem to hail from a
bygone era models posing as if in
paintings
and fashion photos featuring clothes
made of paper and cardboard Swiss
photographer Christian Talia vini makes
the models clothes himself it's a
time-consuming task he usually spends
several months preparing for one single
shoot fashion watches on time to peak
I'm fascinated by the fact that I don't
just release the shutter the real fun
for me is before I take the pictures I
always say I'm not really a photographer
but a craftsman of photography I like to
play it designing and creating clothes
no one can really wear impossible
identify Rea like in the 2008 photo
series de midi Cardona or cardboard
women the designs were inspired by
Baroque styles cubism and 1950s fashions
for earlier projects talia vini used
fabrics but for this project he opted
for cardboard remember being a
supporting Jena seamstress said to me
this fabric is not good it's too stiff
like cardboard so I got the idea of just
making clothes from cardboard I like the
flat stiff cardboard clothes in
connection with the three-dimensionality
of the models
Tahlia meanie released his first
photographic works in 2008 series with
an overriding concepts like chroma
phobia or fear of color or aspect Ando
Freud waiting for Freud the
photographer's greatest success to date
was the portrait series 1503 in which
photos were made to look like old
masters paintings here he used fabric as
well as cardboard his designs drew on
inspiration from the Italian Renaissance
painter via branzino I wanted to
recreate the atmosphere of the
Renaissance with the combination of the
style and artful textiles of the period
Vallejo see what I mean but I didn't
want to simply imitate the paintings of
the Renaissance I wanted to give the
photos my very own style in 2011
Cristian Talia vini exhibited his
Renaissance photos in Paris Milan who
trashed and London and his first
retrospective was shown in Kyoto
Switzerland in early 2012 italia vini
won one of the most prestigious
international accolades for photography
the Hasselblad masters award in the
category of fine art the Swiss
photographer is now able to make a
living from his art and finance the
months of preparation work his cart
series was inspired by historical
playing cards the pictures were created
here in the artist studio in Lugano
Tahlia vini originally studied mechanics
but taught himself photography and
graphic design he does almost everything
himself but does have laser specialists
cut out the costumes he's designed in
paper and cardboard the photographer
experiments with several drafts before
deciding on one working with a model is
just one small part of the process but
it's the honor
knife actually I'm looking for
perfection and that's not easy when I
take a photo I'm never satisfied and I
want to do it again because I try to
devote the greatest attention to every
detail it can take two three or even
five weeks before I have a single photo
these paper and card creations are
products of his imagination so secret I
mean they cast an ironic eye on fashion
especially in my new series here I feel
even more like a fashion designer and
photographer and allow my ideas free
reign the new series was almost a year
in the making
and christian talia Vinnie's next
project is likewise sure to be an
extended labor of love